[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Taylor
starts this hour in Knoxville hi Taylor
how are you hey Dave hey Dr John thank
you so much for taking my call sure
what's
up so I need some help navigating money
and family uh my question is is it wrong
for my husband and I to lie about our
accomplishments and pretend to be broke
in in order to financially and
emotionally protect ourselves and I'm
happy to give a little context with that
it's just
cowardly yeah
yeah yeah I own that yeah
yeah how old are you guys how long y'all
been married Taylor so we've been
married a little over a year together
for five I am 32 and my husband is 35 so
who's the twer that's going to have a
hard time with you
succeeding it's my family uh
specifically my mom okay so my my
husband and I have paid off over
$100,000 in student loans over the last
three years and your mom will feel
entitled to some of your money if she
hears you're
winning correct okay correct all right
um almost like I've talked about this
before okay uhhuh uhhuh okay and uh so
she uses money to show love but more as
a means of control and yeah anytime one
of her kids starts making money she's
got her hand out wanting some And to
clarify she is financially well off and
is not in need of any help um and she
has actually stolen thousands of dollars
from me in the past when I had my very
first job when I was 16 years old and
when IED her we're pretty much we're
pretty much saying mom's got issues yes
why do you continue to allow your mom to
control you you your
30s yeah um I want to honor her as my
mom uh I don't think that's true can I I
don't think that's true I think that
sounds good it's a good church answer
yeah I think you're still trying to
figure out what you did wrong when you
were nine that your mom would steal from
you and you still think there's a way
there's a thing you haven't done yet
that she'll fin you'll finally do it
you'll finally give her the amount of
money you'll finally do the thing and
she'll go I'm so proud of you and I love
you that's what I think you're chasing
and I think you wrap it up in words like
honor thy father and mother honor thy
father and mother does not mean um honor
their misbehavior
exactly yeah uh in all honesty I would
love to just cut her off completely I
don't think I'm ready to do that I think
that's what makes it hard here's what
you're giving her right now you've given
her money in the past you've given her
your um life in the past now you're
giving her your integrity free rent in
your head don't give her your integrity
anymore tell the truth yeah and when she
says well I want like no we're on a
budget it's a muscle you're going to
have to practice you're you're going to
have to you're going to have to it's
like going to the gym you just never
done squats before you're going to have
to start light but you're going to have
to learn how to do squats first time you
do it your heart rate's going to go in
your stomach's going to go into your
throat the 80th time you do it you're
just going to be smiling looking at a
poor pitiful lady who hasn't been able
to control her own
emotions yeah cuz that's actually what
she is it's she's kind of pitiful you
will never do a thing that makes her
finally say cuz she doesn't have that
she don't have that to on her kit she
can't do it she doesn't know how so
you're dealing with an incomplete person
who who's got major major gaps and you
you cannot have any expectation that
she's going to be anything other than
that and you just smile and go no um I
mean pretend like uh she had had a
stroke okay and she was in she was
incapable of uh behaving you would just
look at her and smile and go gosh that's
a horrible malady you've got but that
still doesn't mean you get to come over
here and you know throw rocks through my
window yeah and um we you didn't hear
any of you don't want so bad why you
just kept driving
why H can I okay I'm I'm going to cut to
it you're scared you're going to haunt
your
marriage yeah and at some point your
husband if he hasn't already is going to
ask why her over
me why her over our future that we're
trying to build together yeah she's
taken up a lot of space in your
head so this may be you guys you may
need to sit down and talk to somebody
and work this through because this is a
motherdaughter dysfunction that's pretty
pretty serious and it's just it's just
manifesting itself in the money but it's
there's a lot of others parts of this
and so but the truth is you're not going
to have peace hiding as a 30-year-old
hiding like you're some kind of
misbehaving teenager you know I can't
tell my mom I got good
grades you know I mean come on what so
because she she does not have the
capacity she's a diminished capacity as
if she's had a stroke we'll just call it
that okay and and it affected her
ability to be a good mom and so you just
treat her like that and it's kind of sad
and it's kind of pitiful and but it
doesn't mean I can't tell her the truth
mom you know if it comes up but you
don't need to go in there and go da D
look what we did cuz that's not going to
do it either but you just if it comes up
you just go well you know hey we yeah we
paid off some money but I don't tell I
don't sit down with uh anybody and go
look at what I did yeah how does that
even come up in your house yeah really
well uh when whenever me and my husband
go Which is less and less frequently now
um if I need to go to the restroom or
leave the room they will Corner my
husband and straight up say how much
money did you make this year what are
you making now hold on but but all you
say is I had a good year I don't I'm not
going to give you those numbers and you
smiled real big yeah I don't I'm G to
tell you that it's not your business
yeah or when you come out of the
bathroom go hey Mom Dad we don't talk
about private financial matters anymore
we just don't we don't put those numbers
out into the world those are private
those are ours and if they can't honor
that boundary then they're asking you ah
we don't want you
here yeah right that that could be the
exit that I'm looking for no it could be
but that would be them running you off
not you yelling I'm leaving until you
learn to behave that's not what we're
telling you okay yeah I don't want I
don't want I don't want I don't want I
don't want to talk about my sex life
with you I don't want to talk about my
like the dollar am amount we made last
year I don't want to talk about any
number of things that's for us it's not
for you as I started having grandbabies
I have had way more information from my
children about the arrival of children
and how they got here than I wanted to
know I'm just telling you so I just
assume we went her Direction and just
said you know y y'all just keep that to
yourself I really don't want to know
some of this I just want to see the baby
when it comes thank you very much I'm
happy I don't need to know about the
practice n thank you very much it's all
good but oh my gosh yeah it's the same
stuff you're exactly right you're
exactly right I'm not going to tell you
about that stuff no no papa Dave don't
want to know n Papa Dave don't want to
know I'm just saying want to meet the
baby that's I just show just tell me
what the name is and tell me what the
sex is when it's appropriate to tell me
and then tell me when I can tell people
that and then I will and don't tell me
unless you want me to tell somebody
unless you tell me not to tell them I
need America to know I had a great joke
that I didn't just use you didn't use it
create your free every dollar budget
today the simplest way a budget for your
life